nous sommes engagés du coup pleinement
déjà depuis depuis quelques temps pour
en reparler au cours de cette audition
sur la procédure de renouvellement des
autorisations
respectives de TF1 et M6 qui comme vous
le savez arrive à échéance au mois de
mai 2023 donc il y a un compte à rebours
calendaire qui est dans ces déjà
enclenché
une consultation publique des acteurs du
secteur est en cours on a laissé un
petit peu plus de temps aux acteurs
contenus de la décision de Bouygues et
de retirer son son dossier donc cette
consultation publique prendra fin le 10
octobre prochain à l'issue de cela donc
nous allons au vu des contributions que
nous allons recevoir élaborer notre
étude d'impact que prévoit que prévoit
la loi qui sera naturellement publié
conformément au texte législatif
et puis ensuite il y aura la procédure
d'appel à candidature formelle examen
des candidatures sélection des alors
après audition et négociation des
conventions des futurs titulaires de ces
autorisations donc c'est un chantier
très lourd de longue haleine et
inutile de le souligner devant vous à
Forges et nous menons en parallèle donc
comme vous le voyez on ne chôme pas loin
de là le renouvellement en cours de
l'autorisation de Canal+ puisque Canal+
est arrivé en fin d'autorisation elle
aussi en 2023 la chaîne a souhaité que
son autorisation soit renouvelée ce qui
était son droit et nous avons répondu à
ce drame et nous sommes maintenant dans
la phase de finalisation de la
convention liée au renouvellement de
cette autorisation
aux côtés des acteurs privés
l'audiovisuel public et lui aussi engagé
dans un processus de transformation vous
savez combien le Lacom est attaché au
service public la loi nous change de
veiller à son indépendance et au
pluralisme de l'audiovisuel public
je rappelle que c'est 30% de l'audience
en radio comment télévision c'est un
poids économique de l'ordre de 4
milliards et demi qui est un petit peu
plus faible que le poids économique du
service public en Angleterre ou en
Allemagne mais c'est des acteurs et des
Sociétés nationales qui jouent un rôle
fondamental dans l'équilibre du paysage
audiovisuel en matière d'information ou
en matière de d'offre de programme avec
un soutien en particulier décisif pour
le financement de la création et donc
nous sommes très attentifs on a fait
plusieurs reprises connaître notre
opinion y compris de vendre votre
commission vous vous la savez vous le
savez attentif aux financement de
l'audiovisuel public
nous avons vu le choix qui ont été
opérés notamment pour la loi de finances
pour pour 2000 pour 2023
et nous serons bien évidemment on va
pouvoir en parler j'imagine très
attentif à la suite à l'avenir du
service public
et nous souhaitons de ce point de vue là
que la période qui s'ouvre on aurait
peut-être d'ailleurs souhaité qu'on
commence par ça soit l'occasion d'avoir
une vraie réflexion sur quelle vision
avons-nous du service public à
l'ambition avant nous sur le service
public qu'elle organisation
souhaite-t-on pour le service public
quel gouvernance envisage-t-on et donc
elle financement souhaite pour ce
service public donc nous souhaitons que
la période qui s'ouvre soit notamment à
travers les débats parlementaires
l'occasion de cette réflexion
je pourrais pas énumérer tous les
dossiers mais je souhaite quand même
évoquer quelques dossiers qui sont
également en cours les premiers
concernent nos compétences en matière de
cohésion sociale
j'en cite un parce qu'il est nouveau
c'est la mise en oeuvre de la loi climat
et résilient ce que vous avez le
Parlement adopté ce texte prévoit la
conclusion de charte d'engagement des
acteurs de la publicité sous l'égide du
législateur pour tendre vers une
publicité plus verte pour résumer les
choses d'une formule à ramasser cette
mission
conforte notre action pour réduire
l'empreinte environnementale des acteurs
duel du numérique vous savez qu'on
travaille sur ces sujets conjointement
avec avec l'ARCEP et donc on a coordonné
les acteurs de l'audiovisuel aussi pour
qu'il conclut ses shorts ils ont déposés
sur le site du ministère de
l'Environnement les engagements qu'ils
ont pris que ce soit au titre de leur
gouvernance propre leur RSE ou que ce
soit à travers les programmes qui
portent pour faire partager par les
Français les bonnes pratiques à avoir au
regard de la problématique de la
transition numérique deuxième dossier
que j'évoque aussi qui nous a beaucoup
occupés c'est le soutien à la création
française
vous savez tout le cadre réglementaire a
été révisé donc les décrets
SMAD TNT Capsa donc il nous amène à
revoir à revoir notamment les
conventions qui nous liées aux
opérateurs le point central ça a été la
conclusion pour une première période de
convention avec les grands acteurs
américains qui ciment notre territoire
donc Netflix Amazon Prime Disney plus
pour ne citer que cela mais il y en a
d'autres
c'est un dossier qui est en dans une
phase de mouvement continue la question
de la chronologie des médias est bien
évidemment un sujet très important ce
qu'il faut retenir quand même
aujourd'hui c'est que ce qui est en
œuvre au titre de la transposition de la
directive SMMA est aujourd'hui unique
suivante unique en Europe le niveau de
financement que nous avons
collectivement par la transposition de
cette directive par les textes
réglementaires qui ont été mis en oeuvre
par l'action du régulateur et par
l'implication des opérateurs le niveau
de financement n'a aucun équivalent dans
les pays de l'Union celui qui nous suit
mais encore de loin c'est l'Italie et
donc l'exception culturelle française a
été a été très fortement très fortement
défendu et préservé par le travail
collectif des autorités françaises il
faut je crois sans réjouir
voilà donc le sanglier depuis sa
création l'arcom a donc déployé ses
missions nouvelles poursuivi ces
missions historiques
un petit mot puisque j'ai la chance
d'être devant vous aujourd'hui et que le
débat parlementaire va bientôt commencer
vous savez que depuis bonne dizaine
d'années maintenant l'autorité à assurer
le déploiement de ses missions en
attendant de ses missions nouvelles à
effectif et budget constant
et une fois n'est pas coutume donc nous
avons sollicité un renforcement de nos
moyens pour porter les nombreuses et
nouvelles missions et complexe mission
parce que c'est de les régulations d'un
genre nouveau qui nous faut maintenant
déployer au titre de la loi de finances
pour pour 2023
le projet de loi de finance nous a nous
a ce stade entendu et j'espère en tout
cas je sollicite le concours de
l'ensemble des formations politiques qui
sont représentées au parlement pour
venir à l'appui de notre de notre action
bien sûr à votre disposition pour
répondre vos questions merci monsieur le
Président et nous allons commencer la
série de questions par celle de Jean
Raymond Hugonnet rapporteur
décrédibilités de l'audio merci
président
merci président pour ce voilà ce
panorama cette synthèse de l'activité
de l'arcome comme l'a dit le président
Lafont dans son propos luminaire
l'autorité que vous précidez l'arcome
avait indiqué que des remèdes
raisonnables
pouvaient permettre de répondre aux
préoccupations sectorielle suscité par
le projet de rapprochement je vise bien
évidemment l'actualité encore fraîche
comment expliquer vous la divergence
d'analyses avec l'Autorité de la
concurrence et pensez-vous toujours que
cette fusion était possible au regard du
droit et de l'intérêt du secteur
par ailleurs le groupe berthelsman
semble décider à poursuivre la session
de M6 dans les plus brefs délais
plusieurs candidats ont manifesté leur
intérêt vendredi dernier certains ayant
déjà une présence dans les médias
d'autres pouvant être considérés comme
des nouveaux entrants
quel serait la durée minimale d'examen
parcome d'un nouveau projet de
rapprochement
est-ce que le calendrier serait plus
long si l'acheteur est déjà un acteur
important du secteur des médias
et est-ce qu'il y a un risque que
l'examen par les différents régulateurs
ne soient pas achevés avant le début du
printemps étant donné ce calendrier très
très contraint enfin est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui pourrait amener l'arcome à
ne pas renouveler en mail à licence du
nouveau propriétaire de M6
concernant toujours et c'est ma
troisième et dernière question
concernant toujours nos différents qui
opposent TF1 et Canal+ on peut rappeler
que le législateur avait renoncé à agir
en 2018
lors d'un précédent conflit de même
nature afin de ne pas avoir à se
prononcer sur le principe de la
rémunération du signal des chaînes de la
TNT
ne pensez-vous pas que l'adoption d'une
disposition législative concernant
l'extension du muscari que vous semblez
appelé de vos vœux
risque de rouvrir le débat sur le
principe même de la rémunération du
signal on peut en effet rappeler que les
chaînes publiques ne font pas l'objet
d'une rémunération pour leur signal et
que cela constitue une forme de
contrepartie à l'obligation de
distribution dont elle bénéficie
du Président je vais vous laisser
répondre à cette première série de
questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
permettez-moi de prendre
un petit temps pour correspondre à votre
première question
pour pour redire je l'ai exposé dans
rapidement dans mon propos illuminaire
que la procédure d'instruction de ce
projet de fusion qui était bien
évidemment chacun en a conscience un
enjeu majeur pour le paysage audiovisuel
français
[Musique]
se traduisait par une double instruction
parallèle une instruction devant
l'Autorité de la concurrence d'une part
au titre de son champ de compétences qui
est le droit le droit de la concurrence
qui est applicable dans notre dans notre
pays et puis la procédure de changement
de contrôle et d'agrément du changement
de contrôle devant l'arcom conformé à la
loi c'est deux procédures qui
cheminaient en parallèle chacune avec sa
problématique droit de la concurrence du
côté de l'autorité de la concurrence
principe posé par la loi de 86 au titre
des médias audiovisuels et qui se résume
par un mot qui est celui du plus
réalisme au sens large du terme qui est
vraiment le cœur le cœur du métier du
régulateur que nous sommes
au titre de sa mission donc l'autorité
de la concurrence a souhaité recueillir
la vie de plusieurs autorités le nôtre
celui de celui de la recette s'affaire
de ma part je crois qu'ils ont également
consulté là la CNIL et donc nous avons
répondu à la demande de l'autorité de la
concurrence avec un avis très
circonstancié
et si les membres de la commission en
ont le loisir et le temps
j'en conseille volontiers la lecture
d'abord c'est ta vie dit très clairement
en préambule donc c'est l'avertissement
chapeau qui a bien deux procédures et
que sur notre champ de compétence qui
n'est pas couvert par cet avis le marcom
aurait été amené à donner un avis
spécifique sur la façon dont nous voyons
la problématique du pluralisme au regard
de cette opération nous sommes contentés
de répondre à l'Autorité de la
concurrence sur les problématiques de
nature économique qui sont de sa
compétence c'est bien ça l'objet et donc
l'analyse qui était la nôtre comme
régulateur sectoriel des marchés de la
publicité du marché de la distribution
et du marché des différents droits de
production cinéma audiovisuel sportif
on a construit cet avis vous le verrez
c'est un volumineux il fait une centaine
de pages en deux parties une première
partie c'est peut-être ça là que
j'inviterai les membres de votre
commission à regarder attentivement
au-delà de la synthèse une synthèse est
toujours bien sur un parfait
la première partie elle est consacrée à
analyser le paysage audiovisuel tel que
nous le voyons aujourd'hui en étant le
plus prospectif qu'on puisse l'être à la
date d'aujourd'hui un exercice toujours
difficile qu'une prédire l'avenir mais
on a essayé de voir quels étaient les
tendances de fond qui était aujourd'hui
à l'oeuvre dans le paysage et vous
verrez dans ce panorama il est
impressionnant de voir les évolutions
qui sont aujourd'hui à l'heure et je
crois je vais dire plusieurs reprises
depuis je préside cette autorité qu'on
aurait tort de sous-estimer ces
évolutions je le dis à la fois pour le
secteur privé et je le dis aussi pour le
secteur public
c'est des entreprises qui aujourd'hui
doivent s'adapter à un environnement qui
se traduit par une très profondévolution
des usages on a une baisse continue de
la durée écoute
individuel des
téléspectateurs l'arrivée de nouveaux
acteurs le fait que les écrans sont
maintenant connectés à 80 % que les
usages sont beaucoup plus fracturés six
écrans moyen de parfois par foyer donc
il y a vraiment des tendances de fond et
donc il en résulte une obligation pour
les acteurs publics comme privé
j'insiste bien sur le fait que ça
concerne tout autant de services publics
de pouvoir dégager les capacités
d'investissement requises pour faire à
la fois les investissements
technologiques nécessaires pour toucher
les publics là où ils sont
le public de la télévision vieillit
dangereusement aujourd'hui c'est un
enjeu majeur pour le privé comme pour le
public et en même temps qu'on sentir les
investissements nécessaires pour
financer une création de haut niveau
pour faire face aux évolutions aux
évolutions du paysage et une
augmentation à l'augmentation des coûts
en particulier du fait de la concurrence
croissante qui règne entre les acteurs
donc c'est une première partie en disant
voilà aujourd'hui quel est le paysage
dans lequel on est et voilà un peu les
tendances qui sont les nôtres et puis
dans une deuxième partie on a identifié
les risques que comporter cette
opération et cette opération comporter
des risques et comporter des risques en
matière publicité on la signaler et vu
de notre point de vue et comportait un
risque au titre du pluralisme externe et
c'est ça qu'on a traité dans cet avis le
pluralisme externe c'est quoi c'est quel
effet cette opération aurait eu sur les
autres acteurs de la TNT vous savez que
le chien de la TNT sont en mauvaise
situation économique fragile TF1 M6 ce
sont des chaînes solides qui
fonctionnent bien mais cette aurait eu
des conséquences au titre du marché
publicitaire sur les acteurs les plus
fragiles donc on a soulevé comme
régulateur sectoriel ce risque lié à
cette opération et on a évoqué
on n'a pas eu la présomption la
prétention pardon de vouloir se
substituer à l'autorité de la
concurrence par nature que c'était le
métier j'ajoute qu'on a les meilleurs
relations avec cette autorité avec
lesquels les relations sont à la fois
très confiantes très fluide et vraiment
de de très bonnes loi voilà on a évoqué
une petite série de familles de remède
dont des remèdes structurels je signale
qu'on évoquait des sessions de chaîne
supplémentaires par exemple ça n'a pas
été relevé les directions générales de
la concurrence la elle-même dans son
propre dans son propre avis
donc il y avait des remèdes structurels
on a soulevé également les risques pour
la distribution
a fait de même de son côté dans une
tonalité qui est celle du régulateur des
télécoms mais avec une approche qui
était grosso modo la même et on a
souligné les risques sur le marché des
droits en indiquant très clairement que
si ce cette opération devait se faire ça
supposerait qu'il y a quand même en tout
cas des remèdes suffisants pour garantir
une pluralité de guichet de financement
et surtout pour garantir une un mieux
disant culturel sur la faire
donc je considère pas pour ma part qui
est vraiment de différence d'approche
voilà on a considéré nous aussi qu'il y
avait des risques on a donné notre point
de vue et notre piste de remède en tant
que régulateur sectoriel avec notre
vision à nous du paysage audiovisuel
l'Autorité de la Concurrence a donné son
analyse sur la façon dont elle voyait
les marchés de la publicité c'est sa
mission c'est son alors à partir de là
les acteurs ont retiré leur dossier
n'ont pas le dossier c'est arrêté alors
j'embrais sur votre deuxième question
j'en ai dit un mot je suis je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail bien évidemment
pour des raisons évidentes
le dossier qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
c'est le renouvellement des
autorisations
[Musique]
c'est un dossier connu
début de l'année prochaine elle est deux
autorisations tombent définitivement la
loi nous impose donc de repartir à zéro
et de lancer un appel à candidature avec
des étapes précédentes qui sont en cours
donc consultation publique de tous les
acteurs je l'ai dit à des temps court on
publiera une étude d'impact
pas exactement à quel moment ils ont
coupé courant pour enfin novembre on
laissera aux acteurs le temps de réagir
à notre étude on lancera l'appel à
candidature puis après on verra qui est
candidat on examinera ses candidatures
en deuxitionnera les candidats puisque
la loi prévoit que les auditions sont
publiques et ensuite on statuera et on
négociera les conventions pour être à
pied d'oeuvre et avoir des titulaires
d'autorisation en ordre de marche à
l'échéance des autorisations actuelles
donc ça c'est notre feuille de route du
moment c'est en cours et c'est un
processus sur lequel on déroulera la loi
telle qu'elle est fixée
alors maintenant je lis les journaux
comme vous
je vois qu'on parle d'options possibles
à la date où je vous parle nous sommes
saisit de rien
je redis simplement devant vous que si
on devait être saisi de quelque chose
aussi une opération de devait se faire
sur le changement de capital de de cette
société qui est titulaire d'une
autorisation elle serait soumise donc de
par la loi à la procédure d'agrément du
changement de contrôle par la com avec
l'obligation de refaire une étude
d'impact spécifique de rendre
publicitaire d'impact recueillir les
réactions à cette étude d'impact
le calendrier
[Musique]
et plus ultra serré
mais il est encore faisable
[Musique]
calendrier est extrêmement serré
vraiment extrêmement clair de devant
vous je le dis ici très clairement
le processus d'appel à candidature fixe
un compte à rebours qui rend les choses
extrêmement contraignantes et
extrêmement serrées plus que serré et
j'ajoute mais le président de l'Autorité
de la concurrence il a très bien d'hier
soir que nous ne pourrions statuer sur
un éventuel changement de contrôle de la
chaîne M6 qu'après que les autorités de
la concurrence qu'elles soient
bruxelloise ou nationale et statué donc
il faudrait que ces procédures
s'emboîtent donc quand je dis que le
calendrier est très serré je dis que le
calendrier est très très serré
trois troisième point alors TF1 canal
oui
[Musique]
cette deuxième question très rapidement
mais j'avais rajouté que qu'est-ce qui
pourrait amener l'arcon à ne pas
renouveler en mai la licence de M6 après
je pas anticipé sur le délibéré vous
savez c'est comme le président de la
commission des facteurs et moi je gère
un collègue
c'est un collège de 9 membres avec des
personnalités fortes
des services dirigés par directeur
général qui est persuadé non moi aussi
forte donc voilà il faut laisser à
l'instruction le temps de se faire au
collège le temps de délibérer
si vous voulez bien
TF1 canal je vous donne le fond de ma
pensée c'est bon c'est un litigieux
purement commercial purement commercial
c'est des acteurs
où les entendez régulièrement
ils sont des adeptes de la liberté du
commerce et de l'industrie très bien que
le marché montre son efficacité que la
main invisible d'Adam Smith montre sa
capacité à résoudre le conflit
vu de notre point de vue ce qui n'est
pas acceptable je le dis devant rouge
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de m'exprimer
c'est que le téléspectateur soit pris
dans un litige commercial
qui est une différentielle de prix et
une négociation
voilà je demande tellement temps de
rémunération je trouve que c'est trop je
te demande moins je te demande plus
voilà ça c'est les règles du marché très
bien mais le téléspectateur il a pas à
être canalisé dans cet exercice puisque
l'Esprit de la TNT vous le savez bien
c'est l'accès de tous les Français
Gratuitement sur l'ensemble du
territoire y compris
dans les zones blanches dans les zones
on peut pas avoir de pylônes
au signal et donc j'ai proposé aux
acteurs
l'opération dont on vient de parler
peut-être pas contribué complètement à
la sérénité des débats à plusieurs
reprises plusieurs d'entre vous
connaissent bien un processus de
médiation
très volontiers fait à ce stade nous ne
sommes pas arrivés ils ont préféré la
voix du tribunal de commerce tribunal de
commerce a rendu une première décision
une autre procédure pendant de vente
tribunal de commercial initiative de
canal je le dis clairement devant vous
moi je souhaite qu'on trouve une
solution et la solution elle est à
portée de main pour ce que je connais du
dossier elle est vraiment à portée de
main donc que les acteurs se remettent
autour de la table je suis disponible 24
heures sur 24 pour le faire dès que les
deux parties le souhaiteront et si c'est
pas le cas parce que ces affaires sont à
répétition moi je commençais à avoir
l'espoir que le marché avait mûri et que
elle est partie commencer avec le marché
commencer à trouver un point d'équilibre
si c'est pas le cas je l'ai dit il
faudra que le législateur complète le
texte le texte de loi pourquoi parce que
la loi actuelle donc elle impose aux
éditeurs
une obligation de mettre à disposition
leur signal donc ça c'est l'esprit la
TNT donc ce que les Anglo-Saxons
appellent un must deliver donc l'éditeur
doit mettre à disposition son cylindre
mais il impose pas au distributeurs au
type de la liberté du commerce de
reprendre le signal et là dans le cas
d'espèces de Canal+ le problème et c'est
ça que j'ai visé dans mon propos c'est
la diffusion satellitaire c'est pas la
négociation sur les programmes
complémentaires que portent TF1
vis-à-vis de canal c'est vraiment sur
cette diffusion satellitaire
et là je pense qu'il y a deux options il
y en a une qui était dans le dernier
projet de loi du visuel qui n'a pas été
adopté que vous connaissez bien monsieur
le rapporteur qui pouvait donner aux
régulateur un pouvoir de mesure
conservatoire dans une procédure de
règlement différente permettrait au
régulateur de dire pas de coupure de
signal maintenant on se met autour de la
table on négocie donc ça serait une
première voie de réponse
l'autre voit ça serait d'imposer au seul
diffuseur satellite alors mon idée
n'était pas un must Carey comme pour le
service public au seul diffuseur
satellitaires la reprise du signal que
l'éditeur a l'obligation de mettre à
disposition bon j'espère que la raison
finira pas l'emporter c'est mon
optimisme probablement Béa mon côté
alors peut-être
trop optimiste je me désespère jamais de
la nature humaine
[Musique]
et donner la parole maintenant à un
représentant par groupe et donc par
ordre successifs Catherine Morin deci
David la souligne Monique de Marco
Julien barjoton et Céline Brulin
merci président d'avoir organisé cette
audition du président de la Recon et
celle de l'Autorité de la concurrence
hier
c'était très utile car et notre
rapporteur a été notre porte-voix
face à l'incompréhension de deux avis
totalement divergents sur le
rapprochement TF1 M6 pour ma part mais
si je respecte bien entendu le travail
des autorités indépendantes la vie
qu'elles émettent j'avoue être un peu
dans une forme d'incompréhension par
rapport d'ailleurs à ce que vous avez
dit monsieur le Président il faut savoir
être prospectif savoir ce que sera le
paysage audiovisuel de demain et me
semble qu'actuellement les règles de la
concurrence d'ailleurs ça a été démontré
au niveau européen sont inadaptés à la
nouvelle concurrence des plateformes
salaire du tout numérique et ça vaut
pour bien d'autres secteurs d'ailleurs
que le seul secteur
audiovisuel donc on a l'impression que
le grand bénéficiaire de ça ça va être
en fait le marché publicitaire et non
pas les éditeurs de programme dont
dépend ce marché d'ailleurs publicitaire
donc on a l'impression que c'est avoir
une vision court termiste des choses moi
je voudrais vous interroger plus
particulièrement sur votre
réorganisation à l'époque quand nous
avions parlé de la fusion adoptie CSA
nous envisagions aussi un rapprochement
avec la recette pas une fusion d'un
rapprochement où en êtes-vous de se
rapprochement comment travaillez-vous
avec la recette comment travaillez-vous
aussi avec les autres autorités
indépendantes la CNIL et je voudrais
aussi citer Lancy car on voit le net les
questions de cyber pornographie
cyber-harcèlement c'est de la
cybersécurité donc tout ça est très
corrélé et je pense que les autorités de
régulation a gagné à travailler de
manière extrêmement étroite quid des
moyens aussi donc vous avez pu
bénéficier à la faveur de et comment
vous projetez vous pour le PLF 2023 je
crois que cette question des moyens est
tout à fait essentielle pour les
autorités de régulation une autre
question est sur le volet nouvelle
compétences à manipulation l'information
en tout cas la régulation par des mois
des des plateformes vous avez évoqué le
bilan de la loi
dite
anti-infox je rappellerai que l'ensemble
de cette commission c'était opposé au
texte chose assez rare à l'époque et
nous d'ailleurs le conseil social avait
invalidé à certains de mesures de ce
texte nous donnons raison pensez-vous
que le DS à l'application
digitroce avec ses actes dans l'État va
vous permettre de substantiellement
améliorer cette régulation des
plateformes pour ma pop en avoir été
rapportée au nom de la commission des
affaires européennes je pense qu'on est
encore en deçà
des en termes de moyens notamment
l'interdiction de la publicité pour les
jeunes enfants la transparence des
algorithmes évalués par des autorités
indépendantes et non pas les plateformes
elles-mêmes je pense qu'il y a encore
des marges de de progression mais malgré
tout pouvez-vous nous en dire quelques
mots un petit mot également sur la lutte
visant à combattre la surexposition des
enfants aux écrans notamment les moins
de 3 ans parce que nous avons voté aussi
ici un texte qui d'ailleurs été repris
dans comme amendement dans le texte
visant à
installer une une
autorisation parentale
avez-vous les moyens de mener ses
campagnes d'information pour les tous
bottines notamment parce que c'était pas
le cas il y a il y a quelques années et
comment vous vous y prenez vous
voilà cette protection des tout-petits
et puis dernière question qui n'a pas
grand chose à voir avec ce que je viens
de d'évoquer
il y a le renouvellement
où de nouvelles candidatures bien sûr
pour France media mon et Radio France
quelles vont être les critères
dont le CSA va se doter pour procéder à
ces recrutements bien entendu je pose
ces questions dans le respect total de
l'indépendance de l'autorité qui a
procédé à ces recrutements merci
beaucoup monsieur le président David de
souligne
merci monsieur le Président
merci aussi
[Musique]
à Monsieur recolivier Mestre de son
exposé de d'être devant nous comme
régulièrement
comment ça toucher à
ce qu'il est plus possible d'assumer le
fait pour vous
de réguler
un cadre audiovisuel et un paysage
audiovisuel alors que tout le monde
législateur et vous-même pensez
que les règles que vous devez faire
appliquer soit obsolète
comment ça toucher aux limites si tout
le monde dit la loi de 86 n'est plus le
cadre adapté
et que vous vous êtes chargé dans le cas
de la loi de 86 de réguler un moment
donné c'est plus possible
et
c'est aussi ce qui s'est passé avec les
différences d'appréciations sur la
fusion TF1 M6
bien entendu que la révolution numérique
a bougé le cadre
mais il y a aucune
règle de la concurrence qui a bougé donc
l'autorité de la concurrence juge selon
les règles actuelles de façon
impitoyable donc juste parce qu'elle
applique la règle et vous-même être plus
dans l'interprétation parce que vous
êtes moins sous la des règles qui
apparaissent strictes et donc vous dites
dans c'est possible si il faut aussi ça
ça bon problème c'est que tout le monde
savait que à partir du moment
où TF1 et M6 je parle des deux chaînes
puissantes
fusionner c'est pas en cédant les autres
pixels de la TNT que le pluralisme la
diversité
etc aller
se modifier bon donc je pose ce constat
aussi pour vous dédouer parce que ça
commence à être un exercice difficile
donc est-ce que à un moment donné on
leur réclame tous on sera pas d'accord
sur quelle nouvelle régulation quelle
nouvelle loi 86 comment l'aménager parce
que on a un certain nombre à dire qu'il
faudra
limiter des concentrations trop
puissantes d'autres diront donc au
contraire il faudra
aller jeunesse mais en tous les cas j'ai
entendu un message qui venait de
président de l'Autorité de la
concurrence
apparaît tout à fait important qu'il
faudra un moment réfléchir à dans cette
histoire faut davantage de la
concurrence des plateformes étrangères
qui fragilisent nos entreprises l'autre
marché est-ce que
nous nous orientons vers pour permettre
cette concurrence on se met sur leurs
règles et on fait que nos entreprises et
les mêmes avantages que ces plateformes
ou est-ce que au fur et l'inverse
c'est-à-dire qu'on oblige ces
plateformes dans le cadre européen et
dans le cas de français à rentrer sur
nos critères qui préservent la diversité
l'exception culturelle etc bien entendu
c'est la deuxième option qui à mon avis
devrait faire réfléchir législateur en
tous les cas moi je l'attends un moment
donné un cri d'alarme de l'arcom auprès
des pouvoirs publics
sur le fait que ça devient difficile
pour vous
de réguler dans un cadre que tout le
monde
proclame obsolète
c'est quand même à vous de lire
donc on va le dire aussi
sur une deuxième question parce que dans
votre bilan
puisqu'on parle aussi du bilan de tout
ce que vous avez eu à traiter
vous avez bien constaté plus que
d'autres que il y a eu une polémique
Kaby en exergue notre commission
d'enquête aussi
aborder plusieurs sujets
chaîne d'info ou chaîne d'opinion
et la convention
que vous avez signé avec ces news je
vais pas la relire les devants
et très clair sur et c'est une chaîne
d'information et qu'elle a des
obligations de promouvoir la lutte
contre les discriminations la diversité
etc etc bon or vous les avez condamnés à
plusieurs reprises je vais passer les
épisodes des gradations des
condamnations et ça serait bien
d'éclairer le législateur quand il y a
un bilan de votre activité sur qui
contrevient
embêtant en face voilà c'est nous c'est
tant de fois canal c'est tant de fois là
où il y a zéro pour d'autres
et notamment
quand
excusez-moi c'est toujours compliqué
et notamment
oui oui ça va
voilà donc je demande je demande
est-ce que si on a de quoi payer des
amendes
parce qu'on compte bien
est-ce que ça suffit pour pouvoir
continuer à faire ce qu'on veut pas être
ça arrive souvent dans la société hein
je suis riche peut
me passer des règles parce que je peux
payer mais maintenant
qu'elle est quand ça continue quand ça
contrevient quand c'est aussi cynique
parfois parce que on fait comme si cette
puissance ne peut pas être arrêté
quelle à quel moment et de quelle façon
vous pouvez faire stopper quelque chose
qui n'est pas bon sur le yoga public
j'aurais posé une question mais je pense
que laquelle j'aurais bien aimé que vous
nous disiez
vous savez qu'on a eu un débat sur le
financement on a un financement on va
dire entre guillemets assuré par la TVA
une portion de la TVA pendant deux ans
ensuite bon quelle est votre sentiment
parce que notamment sur le fait que
c'est bien le financement pérenne
est stable qui permet l'indépendance de
l'audiovisuel public et que nous sommes
inquiets nous avons montré ici qu'on
avait une inquiétude là
Monique de Marco merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur c'est un
sujet que vous avez déjà abordé au début
de votre présentation et je reviens sur
celui-ci cela concerne donc le rapport
de la délégation au droit des femmes qui
a mené des travaux sur l'industrie
pornographique
plusieurs pistes donc ont été proposées
pour encadrer ce milieu et en
particulier la mission propose de
confier à l'arcom de prononcer des sous
sanctions administratives avec des
montants très dissuasifs et imposés au
site porno l'affichage d'écran noir tant
que l'âge de l'internaute n'a pas été
vérifiée vous avez répondu en partie en
disant que vous avez bloqué cette sites
mais là c'est une demande de vraiment de
sanction beaucoup plus importante et la
deuxième donc proposition
elle demande que les préconisations de
la com soient renforcées c'est-à-dire
assermenter les agents de larcome afin
de leur permettre de constater eux-mêmes
les infractions ici pornographiques
accessibles aux mineurs puisque le
possédé actuellement est trop long et
pas assez réactif voilà mes deux
questions que pensez-vous de ces deux
propositions
merci Julien barjoton
merci Messieurs les Présidents alors
deux questions la première sur le DA
plus vous avez parlé mais la feuille de
route 2020-2023 prévoyait donc le
déploiement de la radio date plus et
vous avez dit d'ailleurs que à cause du
covid ça avait été voilà ça a été un peu
décalé est-ce que vous pourriez
légèrement détailler ce que vous avez
dit dans votre présentation initiale ça
c'est la première question la deuxième
question concerne les offres de services
de distribution de communication
audiovisuelle ce qu'on appelle aussi bon
les bouquets etc vous notez dans votre
rapport que
ces offres passent de 74 à 66 soit une
baisse de 11%, on est encore très en
dessous des chiffres de 2019 qu'elle
appréciation portez-vous sur l'évolution
de ces offres de services de
communication individuel pourquoi un tel
un tel changement est-ce que c'est
structurel est-ce que c'est conjoncturel
voilà mes deux mes deux questions
Céline Brulin merci monsieur le
Président vous avez évoqué le la
suppression de la redevance et je vous
rejoins et on a un certain nombre à vous
rejoindre sur ce que vous avez développé
c'est à dire que on aurait besoin d'une
réflexion de grande ampleur sur le sens
les objectifs de l'audiovisuel public
avant même de trancher la nature et le
volume de son financement
mais dans le contexte nouveau créé
est-ce que vous travaillez d'ores et
déjà parce qu'il y a dans ce nouveau
paysage la question de la pérennité et
du financement assuré à terme ou pas de
l'audiovisuel public et il y a la
question de l'indépendance est-ce que
d'ores et déjà vous travaillez à des
pistes qui dans le nouveau contexte créé
permettre de garantir l'indépendance de
l'audiovisuel public qui est aujourd'hui
financée d'une manière différente pour
au moins un court terme deuxième
question vous avez évoqué les délais
extrêmement contraints et vous avez
insisté sur la le caractère très
contraint de délai de des nouvelles
autorisations
autour de la fusion avortée de TF1 et de
M6 est-ce que ces délais peuvent être
desserrés
et si ça n'est pas le cas ça laisse
quand même le sentiment
que tout ça était
un peu ficelé
et que
il y a eu un coup de théâtre absolument
inattendu qui fait qu'on est aujourd'hui
dans cette situation là et enfin vous
avez évoqué la nécessité de dégager des
financements très importants vous avez
évoqué le privé mais aussi l'audiovisuel
public et de dégager des capacités oui
d'investissement pour les uns comme pour
les autres mais lorsqu'on regarde
toujours sur le dossier TF1 M6
la proportion de ce que TF1 ou M6 mette
pour élaborer leur grille de programmes
en parallèle de ce que mes Netflix
pour alimenter sa plateforme on est dans
des échelles d'un ordre de grandeur
complètement différente et donc dans les
réflexions à avoir sur les
bouleversements en cours dans le paysage
médiatique audiovisuel etc il y a aussi
ce sujet là c'est à dire que on peut
imaginer toutes les fusions qu'on veut
en clair ça fait pas du tout le poids
par rapport aux plateformes comme celle
que je viens de citer merci
et enfin dernière
merci je voudrais avoir une petite
précision et le regard que vous portez
sur cette fameuse MFA
c'était quand même une compétence
nationale et qui devient européenne
j'aimerais bien un petit peu nous
éclairer deuxième chose vous avez parlé
des mises en demeure pour la protection
des mineurs mais dans son rapport là
comme à une action aussi en faveur de
l'éducation médias et l'information
des jeunes et vous dites qu'elle s'est
intensifié ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un petit peu plus sur cette
éducation après cette question année
vous savez que les télés locales qui
participent quand même au pluralisme
donc on a augmenté le seuil on a demandé
d'ailleurs davantage de 12 à 19 millions
d'habitants est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est suffisant et qu'on doit encore
réclamer plus maintenant et enfin
vous savez qu'on a eu une mission
une mission sur la concentration des
médias qui s'est beaucoup intéressé
d'ailleurs à la à la déontologie des
médias mais est-ce que vous pensez quand
même on devrait aller un peu plus loin
et s'interroger sur la déontologie
carrément des journalistes puisque j'ai
même entendu hier
notre vice-présidente Laurence Rossignol
dire dans une interview que un
journaliste que eux bénéficiaient d'un
code de déontologie le journaliste
d'ailleurs à branché est parvenu de
Fuste qui est pas tout à fait le cas
et je vais oublier le groupe LR donc Max
Brisson
non président
des paroles et tout à l'heure leur
Darcos est un courant sur des sujets
très précis mais j'ai souhaité prendre
la parole après l'intervention de
Monique de Marco pour appuyer ce qu'elle
a dit
et pour compléter ce que vous nique de
Marco a dit je voudrais d'abord vous
remercier président d'avoir cité
abondamment dans votre intervention
préliminaire le rapport de la délégation
droit des femmes approuvé hier
après-midi et publié hier soir
et de revenir en quelques mots sur ce
rapport et sur ce qu'il dit sur la
protection des mineurs vis-à-vis de
l'industrie de la pornographie
dans les préconisations dans les
recommandations du rapport certaines
concernent donc les médias avec par
exemple la mise en place de contrôle
parental automatique Monique de barcoon
a cité d'autres et surtout dans les
recommandations il y a un renforcement
des moyens pour la com et vous avez dans
votre intervention plus globalement
indiquez qui exceptionnellement vous
demanderiez des moyens supplémentaires
pour l'Autorité de régulation donc ma
question est simple en complément de
s'imposer par unique de Marco l'autorité
a-t-elle déjà réfléchi
au moyen ton tel aurait besoin pour
lutter contre ce fléau
quelles sont les actions qui pourraient
être enclenchées par ces moyens
supplémentaires par ces agents serait-il
nécessaire qu'il soit assermenté par
exemple pour être en capacité de
véritablement réduire ce qui est un
fléau que le rapport met en exergue et
qui à mon avis doit interroger l'opinion
publique je pense qu'elle nous par
contre de l'importance croissante de
l'exposition des enfants et des
adolescents à des scènes pornographiques
donc au sujet complexe je n'attends pas
de vous des réponses précises mais
simplement peut-être l'état de la
réflexion sur le sujet de l'autorité de
la régulation
je vais vous laisser monsieur le
Président de répondre à cette question
je sais qu'il y a d'autres orateurs qui
se sont inscrits qui aviendront
interviendront par la suite
merci beaucoup pour l'ensemble de ces
questions qui manifestent bien l'intérêt
des membres de votre commission pour nos
sujets
sur les mineurs par rapport aux écrans
je sais que c'est un thème de
procréation qui vous est cher c'est un
domaine sur lequel on déploie une série
d'actions je vais revenir sur le cas
spécifique du des sites pornographiques
dans quelques minutes donc il y a
plusieurs dispositions qui sont en cours
il y a la loi sur le contrôle parental
qui a été adopté l'année dernière à ce
qu'on appelait la loi Studer qui donne
alors pour le coup une compétence à la
NFR et non pas l'arcom pour veiller à la
façon dont les équipements entiers
mettent en place les dispositifs pour
avoir un dispositif de contrôle parental
par
défaut de notre côté il y a les
campagnes que vous connaissez enfants et
écran qu'on est en train de sur lesquels
on est en train de d'actualiser les
choses on a les campagnes de
signalétique qu'on fait tous les ans
bien connus des Français pour bien
cibler les programmes et leurs horaires
on a déployé en liaison avec la recette
et le gouvernement incite qui s'appelle
je protège mon enfant qui permet
d'informer aisément les familles à la
fois sur les dispositifs de contrôle
parental parce qu'ils sont très nombreux
comme vous le savez pratiquement un
dispositif par type d'équipement mais
plus globalement sur la problématique
de protection des
enfants par rapport aux écrans donc
c'est vraiment un axe un axe d'action
constante de notre institution et c'est
complété bien sûr c'est le sénateur par
une action en matière d'éducation aux
médias l'occasion de rencontrer le
nouveau ministre de l'éducation en début
du mois de septembre on va voir valeur
actualiser notre convention avec
l'Éducation nationale pour bien
embrasser non seulement l'éducation
médias au sens traditionnel du terme
mais également les nouvelles compétences
qui sont les nôtres en matière de
régulation des réseaux sociaux parce que
il faut une action coercitive bien sûr
mais il faut aussi apprendre au plus tôt
à utiliser ces réseaux en citoyens pas
simplement se lâcher parce qu'on est
caché par l'anonymat et également mettre
dans cette convention les thématiques de
lutte contre le contre le piratage qu'il
a aussi doivent s'apprendre ça prendre
plutôt c'est également une action pour
laquelle on a donné élargi la mission de
nos représentations en région les arcoms
qui sont en région pour leur demander
d'être en articulation avec les recteurs
des académies dans lesquels ils sont et
avec tous les médias locaux pour les
inciter là aussi aller plus loin en
matière d'éducation médias nous
développons les actions de formation des
enseignants notamment à Paris on a par
exemple un partenariat étroit avec les
le rectorat de Créteil et donc nous
accueillons régulièrement des
enseignants et puis nous mettons à
disposition ça va ça va monter en gamme
si je puis dire des modules sur notre
site à disposition des enseignants pour
qu'ils puissent développer leur action
leur action d'éducation aux médias
madame le DSA
je voudrais quand même souligner la
chance que nous avons d'être sur un
continent qui s'attache à mettre en
place une régulation des réseaux sociaux
c'est le continent européen et l'actuel
Commission en particulier
ouvre la voie sont un peu pionniers et
sont les premiers pour inventer un
modèle de régulation qui à la fois soit
protecteur de nos valeurs la liberté de
communication au premier chef puisque on
voit certes des excès sur ces réseaux
mais c'est aussi des outils de
communication très très importants ils
font partie de notre vie quotidienne à
tous et en même temps de mieux répondre
aux attentes des opinions publiques
d'une plus grande protection
donc c'est un texte qui est ambitieux
c'est un texte qui est complexe où vous
le connaissez bien puisque vous avez
beaucoup travaillé dessus il y a de très
gros enjeux de mise en oeuvre il y a de
très gros enjeux d'abord pour la
Commission européenne Allemagne
puisqu'il va falloir qu'elle se note
elle aussi d'un outil pour mettre en
œuvre les dispositions de ce texte
on parle d'un service qui nous vaut qui
sera créé on aura nous-mêmes dès la
semaine prochaine des contacts avec les
services de la Commission sur ce point
et puis il va falloir organiser la
gouvernance de ce règlement européen
donc ce bord qui associera les autorités
de régulation nationale
j'y vois une petite difficulté que je
vous cache pas même si on salue on salue
le texte c'est problématique de contenu
illicite sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
des problématiques qui sont d'une
hypersensibilité nationale d'ailleurs
même
juste titre vous exprimez en tant qu'élu
de la nation quand vous êtes interpellé
ou quand vous constatez des excès et la
difficulté de cette gouvernance c'est
que c'est une gouvernance qui préserve
le pays d'implantation
des sites et donc les régulateurs des
pays où sont implantés ces sites et qui
centralisent beaucoup le dispositif au
niveau de la commission donc je pense
qu'on va avoir ça c'est un gros sujet
évoqué avec la commission comment en
articule bien les préoccupations locales
celles que nous au régulateurs nationaux
régulateur national on va avoir pour
répondre aux préoccupations des opinions
publiques nationales et le fait que la
gestion de ce dispositif et lointain ça
c'est la première difficulté que je vois
la deuxième difficulté je vois c'est la
nature de la régulation en matière de
télévision vous êtes intervenu plusieurs
me poser des questions sur le sujet un
programme ne vous plaît pas sur tel ou
telle chaîne monsieur Assouline a évoqué
une chaîne qui lui est chère bon il peut
nous interpeller il manque pas de le
faire d'autres le font on examine les
programmes on regarde si c'est conforme
à la loi ou pas si c'est conforme à la
Convention ou pas et on déploie les
outils que nous avons sur ces réseaux
sociaux qui brassent des centaines de
millions d'informations chaque seconde
on peut pas courir après chaque contenu
les uns après les autres c'est donc ce
qu'on appelle une régulation systémique
que c'est notamment DSA met en place et
des obligations de moyens qui vont être
imposées à ces grands acteurs
qui donneront à la Commission en
articulation avec les régulateurs
nationaux la mission de s'assurer que
ces moyens sont bien mis en oeuvre et
s'ils ne sont pas mis en oeuvre la
possibilité de sanctionner qui mettront
également en œuvre des dispositifs
d'audits extérieurs pour voir ce que
font effectivement les plateformes et
puis qui imposeront aussi à des acteurs
une obligation de transparaître
transparence et d'accès à leur donner et
notamment à leurs algorithmes pour voir
comment ça comment ça fonctionne donc le
texte va dans le bon sens
incontestablement je pense c'est une
belle initiative de l'Union européenne
et il faut saluer le fait conditions
incontinent pionnier en la matière mais
ça va être un art d'exécution et le sens
du message que je que je veux exprimer
sur notre organisation sur laquelle vous
avez posé une question donc je l'ai
indiqué on a revu notre organigramme à
la fois en créant une direction des
plateformes en ligne pour gérer nos
nouvelles compétences et quand j'ai
parlé de renforcement de moyens c'est
cette direction que j'évoque en
particulier
j'avais déjà je crois devant vous mais
j'ai revu récemment une communication
nos homologues anglais qui pour la
régulation des plateformes parlent d'un
service de 300 agents
honnêtement d'ailleurs je me demande ce
qu'ils feront 300 c'est quand même
beaucoup mais bon
nous sommes aujourd'hui avec une
direction qui est encore en moyenneur et
les renforcements de moyens ont pour but
voilà de cette direction des plateformes
en ligne puisse bien gérer les nouveaux
textes divers qui sont les nôtres et
puis on a créé une direction de la
création donc qui mêle
la gestion des obligations de
financement qui pèsent sur les acteurs
de l'audiovisuel et les plateformes de
vidéos par abonnement jusqu'à la lutte
contre le piratage
quant à leur sept range bien noté que
l'idée d'une fusion ne vous effrayez pas
donc je vous remercie de
vouloir étendre le domaine de la lutte
pour l'arcom
bon digérons déjà la première fusion
nous avons une très bonne relation avec
la recette globalement une très très
bonne relation avec l'ensemble des
autoritaires dépendantes on se réunit
périodiquement on a d'ailleurs une
réunion la semaine prochaine je crois
avec l'ensemble de nos homologues donc
on se réduit une fois par semaine chez
les autres pour faire un tour d'horizon
il y a deux jours nous avons réuni
ensemble les deux collèges comme nous le
faisons une fois par semaine de collège
de la recette et du CSA et de l'Arcane
pardon pour balayer nos sujets d'intérêt
commun on a un service commun à la
recette et alors comme sur une série de
sujets j'irai moi-même devant le collège
de la CNIL prochainement pour exposer un
peu les nouvelles missions et voir les
thématiques de dialogue donc voilà il y
a une collaboration qui est vraiment
très bonne et j'évoquais tout à l'heure
l'Autorité de la concurrence on aurait
tort de vouloir nous opposer à
l'autorité la concurrence avec laquelle
la collaboration est très fluide très
très confiante
et très homogène je dirais même si
chacun a son champ de compétence plus
particulière
sur France media monde et Radio France
donc nous sommes dans la phase d'appel
la candidature comme vous le savez
l'appel sera clos le 21 octobre se fait
hors de ma part si ma mémoire ne fait
pas défaut
nous publierons ensuite la liste des
candidatures recevables nous publierons
également les projets stratégiques
puisque la loi impose que chaque
candidat présente un projet stratégique
à l'appui de sa de sa candidature donc
mènerons cela en pleine transparence
nous ferons ensuite des auditions
publiques des candidats
la loi nous fixe comme critère
l'expérience et la compétence et les
deux critères qui sont mentionnés dans
la loi de 86 donc on veillera bien
évidemment aller à les appliquer et nous
statuons au plus tard
nous avons donné cette date publiquement
au plus tard le 15 janvier c'est-à-dire
avant le prochain renouvellement du
collège puisque vous savez pas de
collège sur nouvelle partie à tous les
deux ans donc deux membres vont nous
quitter en janvier de l'année prochaine
pour être remplacé et donc on souhaite
statuer sur ce dossier qui est déjà
enclenché avec le collège actuel nous
d'où ce calendrier de de décision
monsieur le sénateur Assouli on nous
avons déjà souvent et longuement
dialogué sur les questions que vous avez
soulevées et notamment devant la
commission d'enquête sur la sur la
concentration à laquelle nous avons
activement participé nous avions fourni
énormément de matière pour votre commune
Commission on a été redevoir qu'elle
avait été utilisée à profit dans le
rapport de la de la de la Commission
alors la loi de 86 est-elle
définitivement obsolète
[Musique]
vous connaissez ma position je suis plus
nuancier que vous ou pas pas seulement
parce que j'ai un attachement
particulier à cette fois vous le savez
mais simplement parce que je pense que
les principes qui font de cette loi je
serai tenté de dire beaucoup de choses
je dis pas que tout y a beaucoup de
choses hier restent d'une actualité vous
êtes très attaché et je le suis tout
autant que vous à la défense du
pluralisme c'est un principe cardinal de
cette loi elle est tout à fait tout à
fait valable je pense qu'elle a deux
faiblesses cette fois c'est qu'elle a
été modifiée comme vous le savez j'ai
jamais de chiffres à peu près 80 fois
donc au bout d'un moment sa lisibilité
est plus tout à fait donc j'ai eu
l'occasion d'échanger avec le président
Stern pour la de la Commission de
codification le premier travail très
utile serait une codification de cette
loi qu'on a un code
qui résume très clairement les règles
qui sont en vigueur parce que et pour
vous et pour nous et pour le juge je
crois que ça serait pour les
usagers ce serait quand même extrêmement
utile et puis
moi j'ai pas de stylité à l'idée
d'engager un moment la refonte de ce
texte c'est vraiment
bon voilà il a 40 ans d'histoire
pourquoi pas mais bon courage
bon courage
je vous reprends quand même sur
j'ai cru sentir que vous souhaitiez
proposer l'arcom et l'AdlC et donc ça je
voudrais vraiment m'inscrire en faux
là-dessus il y aurait en quelque sorte
une autorité vertueuse qui serait
l'Autorité de la concurrence et puis une
autorité qui serait moins l'arcade je
sais vous lire monsieur le sénateur je
sais vous dire je vous connais depuis
les années je vous connais bien et je
sais je sais décrypter vos propos je
vois très bien le sous-titrage je le
vois très bien le sous-titrage
on applique des règles strictes la PIC
des règles Sinatra non monsieur le
sénateur je peux pas laisser dire ça les
gars
d'une autorité indépendante c'est un
collège qui statut et c'est autorité
applique appliquera les lois vous
commentiez notre action c'est tout à
fait normal c'est le rôle de la
représentation nationale je rendais
compte devant vous vous pouvez tout à
fait estimer que notre action mais je
peux pas laisser dire qu'il y a une
autorité qui staturait en pleine
indépendance parce que c'est ce que vous
avez sous-entendre et une autorité qui
ne l'aurait pas fait donc je voulais
très clairement nous avons eu une
appréciation et je vous mets au défi je
vous mets au défi de savoir ce que nous
aurions dessiné sur le changement de
contrôle de ces groupes puisque nous
n'avons pas statué là-dessus donc vous
ne pouvez pas par définition savoir
quelle position l'autorité aurait pris
sur ce sur ce sujet donc on n'est pas
sur une nous notre feuille de route je
le dis je le redis si je reviens
toujours de la seule feuille de route et
chaque fois qu'il y a une décision
difficile
dans cette autorité ma seule feuille de
route c'est la loi chaque fois je
reprends la loi de 86 je relis le tail
je relis les intentions du législateur
c'est ça notre boussole c'est pas une
interprétation c'est pas l'air du temps
comment je perçois les choses est-ce que
ça serait bien pas bien non que dit la
loi la loi nous charge de défendre le
pluralisme au sens large et bien sûr
cette opération c'est ce que nous
aurions fait et dans notre avis à
l'Autorité de la concurrence nous avons
identifié des risques nous les avons
nous avons très clairement très
clairement exposés sur l'audiovisuel
public je pense qu'on a une approche qui
est pas très différente depuis de
nombreuses années là aussi on en a parlé
un nous sommes les avocats du service
public service public sont un rôle
fondamental pour la cohésion nationale
en matière d'information de
divertissement d'accès à la culture de
soutien à la création
c'est un élément d'équilibre du paysage
et donc nous sommes les avocats de cette
entité publique qui joue un rôle
fondamental et nous avons toujours dit
que nous étions attachés à un
financement pérenne qui donne de la
visibilité à ces entreprises qui sont
très complexes et très et très
difficiles très difficiles à gérer il y
a une solution nous aurions préféré pour
notre part vous le savez qu'on anticipe
sur l'échéance de la taxe d'habitation
et qu'on imagine bref forme de la table
de la redevance parce qu'il fallait
réformer cette redevance c'était pas
c'était pas là alpha et l'oméga alors
redevance c'est d'ailleurs pas parce
qu'il y avait une redevance que les
contributions le dieu public on
progressé donc la réforme était
souhaitable toutes choses égales par
ailleurs le modèle qui nous aurait
plutôt plus à l'arc comme c'était le
modèle allemand d'une taxe universelle
déconnectée des appareils avec les
exonérations sociales qui vont bien donc
une assiette plutôt large qui a joué sur
le sur le taux bon c'est pas le choix
qui a été fait alors comme n'a pas à
discuter ce que le Parlement a décidé le
Parlement a décidé il est souverain ce
que nous souhaitons c'est je l'ai dit et
je réponds je vous réponds madame la
sénatrice que la période qui va entre
maintenant et 2025 soit vraiment mise à
profit pour engager une réflexion sur le
devisole public sur ces missions sur son
organisation notre conviction c'est
qu'il faut aller vers plus de
convergence entre les entreprises le
service public gagnerait rassembler ses
forces pas pour faire de la
rationalisation administrative
mais simplement pour être plus efficace
il y a des dossiers sur lesquels je
trouve que il faut que les entreprises
aillent plus loin je pense à l'offre de
proximité avoir une belle grande offre
de proximité de service public dans le
contexte de concurrence locale d'acteurs
privés est un enjeu très important pour
le service public avoir une offre
numérique plus homogène de la part du
service public ça me paraît un enjeu
commun qui est fondamental avoir une
stratégie commune en direction des
publics les plus jeunes c'est une
ambition commune et ma deuxième
conviction c'est que si on laisse
simplement les entreprises en leur
disant soyez gentils collaborer entre
vous
les choses n'avanceront pas c'est des
entreprises qui ont des corps sociaux
très très forts
légitime avec un historique très
particulier donc si on veut organiser
cette convergence si on estime que cette
orientation est la bonne je pense que ça
suppose effectivement à un moment de
réfléchir sur la façon dont on pilote
l'organisation de cette de cette
convergence
voilà et monsieur le sénateur à souligne
sur cnews on est intervenus je vais pas
revenir dessus parce qu'on en a parlé
très longuement devant la commission
d'enquête je pourrais reprendre
largement mes propos
nous sommes intervenus et nous
interviendrons sur cette chaîne comme
sur les autres chaque fois qu'il y aura
un manquement un contenu nous le ferons
dans le cadre des principes qui sont
posés par la loi de 86
je rappelle que l'institution a quand
même 40 ans d'histoire et que nous avons
donc plus de 40 ans de jurisprudence du
Conseil d'État de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme donc on sait à peu
près où se situe le curseur entre la
liberté d'expression et les
interventions qu'on peut faire au titre
des sanctions sûrement peut-être mieux
faire et donc
les autorisations comme vous savez elles
ont des échéances j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de dire de vente commission
et dans les critères de renouvellement
des autorisations il y a une phase de
bilan sur la façon dont les conventions
étaient exécutées et notamment sur les
procédures de sanction que le régulateur
a pu être amené à mettre en œuvre au
titre de au titre de la convention donc
c'est un paramètre c'est pas le seul
c'est un paramètre parmi d'autres je
crois que c'était d'ailleurs une piste
que vous évoquez dans votre rapport
d'enquête que j'ai lu très attentivement
de la première à la dernière page y
compris les annexes
et donc ça c'est un travail qui m'a
beaucoup intéressé et je redis devant
vous puisque plusieurs m'ont posé la
question que nous-mêmes je l'avais dit
dans la commission d'enquête nous
appelons de nos vœux à une adaptation du
droit de la régulation le paysage se
transforme
je crois que l'opération convient de
qu'on vient de vivre montre que tout de
même les outils fonctionnent les outils
de régulation qui fonctionnent et les
règles anticoncentration qui
fonctionnent mais ça doit pas nous
empêcher de nous projeter vers l'avenir
il y a un nouveau champ digital nous
avons fait des propositions nous-mêmes
pour que le régulateur que nous sommes
vois ces compétences un peu élargies et
transformées en la matière votre rapport
à des choses sur la table il y a des
états généraux de l'information qui vont
bientôt se tenir ce sera probablement
l'occasion de redébattre de ces sujets
et de voir
d'autorité
c'est pas vraiment du gouvernement
une réponse quand même sur la sur les
sites
je suis quand même frappé que le
législateur est intervenu il y a 2 ans
maintenant la loi sur les violences
conjugales donc août 2020 si ma mémoire
est bonne
nous sommes en septembre
ça me rappeler 22 donc plus de 2 ans
sont écoulés
aucun site n'a pris une initiative pour
se mettre en conformité avec la loi
française
nous les avons mis en demeure
peuvent pas dire qu'ils n'ont pas été
alerté
ils ont présenté une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité devant
le Conseil d'État qui est en cours
d'examen
notre mise en demeure et bien évidemment
été précédé de constater s'assurer de
l'état de l'état des lieux
on a refait des constats après nos mises
en demeure on a vu que rien n'avait
bougé on a saisi la justice
à nouveau une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité a été posée devant le
tribunal judiciaire sur lequel le
tribunal répondra le 30 septembre je
crois ce soir de ma part donc on verra
si elle est transmise à la courte
cassation pour examen éventuellement
derrière au Conseil constitutionnel
pour vous dire qu'on est en face de nous
les acteurs qui feront flèches de tout
bois et ça j'étais très sensible à ce
qui a été dit dans le rapport de la
délégation hier soir sur cette notion
d'industrie l'industrie puissante
donc le régulateur met en oeuvre les
dispositions que le Sénat puisque c'est
un amendement de la sénatrice Mercier
qui a été adopté en l'occurrence sur ces
mises en demeure sur la saisie de la
justice maintenant là-bas elle est dans
le camp de la justice on va voir ce que
la procédure de médiation va donner nous
aurions pour notre part souhaité c'est
ce qu'on avait demandé au tribunal qui
utilise ça faculté de bloquer les sites
purement parce que notre conviction
c'est que tant qu'il y aura pas une
contrainte
se mettront pas pleinement en mouvement
mais on a là une procédure médiation
donc on va jouer le jeu on sera présent
nous-mêmes à la médiation
quand on renfort pourquoi pas les
sanctions financières
soldifient la grosse difficulté que j'y
vois et d'ailleurs nous nous le voyons
dans la mise en œuvre de ces
dispositions c'est que c'est des sites
qui sont pour la plupart hors de France
sur ce que nous assignons il y en a qui
sont à Chypre il y en a qui sont
opportuns il y en a qui sont check-in
donc chaque fois il faut qu'on a une
notifié c'est pas au bureau de poste d'à
côté que se fait l'accusé de réception
c'est à l'autre bout de l'Union il faut
qu'on informe la Commission européenne
parce qu'on est dans le cadre européen
donc c'est des procédures qui sont qui
sont quand même très lourdes
bon en tout cas je vais prendre
connaissance du rapport on réagira sur
l'ensemble des professions on a
contribué à cette mission de la
délégation au roi des femmes
les services de l'arcome avaient répondu
aux auditions
les choses bougent quand même la justice
bouge vous l'avez vu quand même il y a
plusieurs procédures qui sont en cours
des enquêtes qui qui conduisent même à
des incarcérations donc voilà on sent
que l'opinion publique a beaucoup évolué
par rapport à ce qui prévalait ce qui
prévalait il y a quelques années il
faudra très vraisemblablement aller plus
loin
l'audiovisuel public madame la salatrice
je crois que je vous je crois que je
vous ai répondu monsieur le sénateur
barjoton sur la sur le DAB+ alors le
petit retard qu'on a pris bien sûr la
pandémie est lié un peu la crise qu'on
vit en ce moment sur les composants
puisque pour ces matériels de diffusion
il faut des composants et comme vous le
savez il y a une pénurie qui est assez
forte bon donc on est actualisé notre
feuille de route on espère quand même je
le disais tout à l'heure toucher 50% de
la population française fin 2023 donc
les grandes agglomérations sont
couvertes les grands axes routiers
devraient être couverts et après on
complètera progressivement le puzzle
pour tous les Français y a accès vous
avez raison sur les bouquets c'est une
tendance un peu générale que qu'on
observe donc
il faut à la fois veiller à la pluralité
des acteurs bien sûr c'est un élément
qui est important mais en même temps la
compétitivité du du secteur le point de
vigilance pour nous c'est ce mouvement
de
désintermédiation comme disent les
techniciens entre les éditeurs et les
consommateurs qui se développent donc
pas de question est très pertinente
c'est en tout cas un point de un point
de vigilance pour nous
sur la suppression de la redevance
monsieur je crois largement largement
exprimée
l'aime fort alors la même forge un peu
tenté comme le DSA de saluer cette
initiative européenne c'est quand même
bien que le continent européen se dot
un dispositif pour mieux protéger la
liberté d'informer la liberté de
communication
s'intéresser au sujet de concentration
de concentration dans les médias
c'est un texte qui s'est beaucoup
développé entre les idées de départ les
idées de départ visé plutôt quelques
problèmes particuliers sur la frontière
orientale du continent j'allais dire et
puis finalement on est parti sur un
texte qui est beaucoup plus ambitieux
ça sera un peu comme le DSA ça va être
un ordre d'exécution parce que c'est un
texte qui n'embrasse pas que les médias
audiovisuel mais qui embrassent aussi la
presse écrite vous connaissez
l'indépendance farouche de la presse
écrite et on ne peut que la soutenir
bien évidemment donc rentrer dans un
dispositif de régulation on sera
sûrement un élément de un élément de
débat et une deuxième question c'est que
les pays de l'Union ont des corpus
juridiques très différents la France un
corpus très avancé insuffisamment
peut-être mais en tout cas en matière de
règles anticoncentration en matière de
protection de la presse avec la loi de
1880 elle doit 86 pour les médias
audiovisuels d'autres pays n'ont pas ses
règles et donc l'acceptation d'une
supranationale pour tous les acteurs de
l'union sera sûrement délicate et puis
comme pour le DSA il y aura un problème
de gouvernance puisque le texte un
élément positif c'est qu'il prévoit que
le réseau des régulateurs européens dans
lesquels nous sommes donc les regards
deviendraient en quelques recettes en
quelque sorte le conseil je peux quel
est son nom le conseil
conseil des médias enfin c'est lui qui
serait l'instant mais en même temps dans
le texte on voit bien que la Commission
européenne exerce à l'égardes ce conseil
une corde de rappel j'ose pas dire
tutélaire mais quand même assez forte
donc si on veut une régulation des
médias il faut une régulation
indépendante comme ça que nous exerçons
avec les règles de protection de notre
indépendance qui s'y attache donc belle
initiative belle idée un long débat en
perspective au Parlement européen et
entre les États européens et en ordre
d'exécution certainement très très
important sur les télévisions locales
on se le seul vient d'être bougé par le
par le Parlement donc laissons vivre ce
seuil je pense qu'il faut faire
attention aux équilibres entre le
développement des acteurs privés en
télévision locale notre souhait c'est
toujours de voilà la question du
pluralisme c'est préservons la pluralité
du modèle des télévisions locales il y a
des télévisions privées groupe Altis en
particulier qui se développe avec BFM il
y a des télévisions articulaires avec la
presse quotidienne régionale on a validé
l'année dernière la reprise par la
dépêche d'un réseau dans le Sud-Ouest
parce que ça nous paraît important
d'appliquer la presse il y a des
télévisions qui sont totalement
indépendantes en liaison avec les
concerts régionaux et puis il y a le
service public donc je pense qu'il faut
veiller à garder cette pluralité pour
avoir vraiment des modèles des modèles
différents
la déontologie des journalistes
va se programme aurait dit le général
c'est bon c'est un sujet un sujet
récurrent un sujet récurrent mais en
même temps très très délicat
la loi pour l'instant je le répète
souvent ne flèche pour nous que les
personnalités politiques c'est ce que
dit l'article 13 de loi de 86 donc notre
contrôle au dessus du portisme s'exerce
que sur les personnalités politiques
certains voudraient qu'on aille plus
loin que ça touche les éditorialistes
pour l'instant ce n'est pas ce que dit
la loi et moi type personnel j'estime
qu'il faut être très prudent dans cette
voie là on défend assez jamais assez à
mes yeux la liberté et la liberté
d'expression dans les limites qui sont
naturellement posées posées par la loi
sur le renforcement de nos moyens j'en
ai donné quelques indications donc dans
le projet de loi de finance pour l'année
prochaine on prévoit d'augmenter notre
subvention d'un million 8
ce qui nous permettrait donc de recruter
15 collaborateurs donc c'est un état qui
nous on vient en espérant qu'il soit si
suivi encore d'une étape supplémentaire
l'année suivante
et sur l'indépendance
de l'audiovisuel public
[Musique]
bon il y a plusieurs éléments de
l'indépendance d'abord le fait que c'est
nous qui nommons les dirigeants ça je
crois que c'est quand même important de
garder ce modèle confié un régulateur
indépendant le soin de mai le fait qu'on
donne un avis sur tous les textes qui
intéressent le service public tous les
contrats d'objectifs qu'on donne chaque
année un avis sur l'exécution du contrat
d'objectif c'est sur le respect du
cahier des charges qui est un travail
utile pour le Parlement savoir bien
exercer son contrôle sur ces entreprises
sur le financement
moi je serai pas choqué que avant le
débat parlementaire sur le financement
de la deuxième public on demande un avis
à l'arcom par comme à une vision
panoramique du secteur pas très bien
l'ensemble des équilibres le privé le
public
il donne un avis sur tous les textes
qu'on a un bloc de compétences qui est
très homogène très cohérente pourquoi ne
pas solliciter son avis tous les ans sur
le sur le montant de la redevance ça
pourrait être une contribution je sais
qu'il y a d'autres idées qui ont été
avancées monsieur le sénateur dans un
rapport avec le sénateur carochi il y a
quelques il y a quelques mois
ça peut être en tout cas un élément de
d'éclairage un peu comme le Haut Conseil
des finances publiques par rapport à la
loi de finances qui permet d'avoir un
avis un peu extérieur et d'éclairer le
débat le départ parlementaire monsieur
le Président je change m'en voulait
d'avoir été trop loin il y a encore
deux sénatrices qui veulent intervenir
j'ajouterai éventuellement une question
toi de voir
merci monsieur le Président moi je
voudrais juste revenir sur l'une des
nouvelles missions que l'art comme s'est
vu conférer la lutte contre les contenus
haineux en ligne comme vous avez déjà
apporté un certain nombre d'éléments sur
le sujet je vais être brève vous avez
déployé au mois de juillet une cybertas
force pour lutter contre les violences
numériques et vous avez évoqué à
l'Assemblée nationale à un travail de
signalétique en la matière pouvez-vous
nous apporter plus de précisions sur ce
dispositif et surtout ce type d'action
vous paraît-il assez dissuasif ou courir
citif pour pouvoir stopper net un
phénomène qui nécessite une prise en
charge ferme et rapide merci
merci monsieur le Président moi je
voulais revenir sur la difficulté de
mise en oeuvre du décret ce Mad monsieur
le Président car je crois que c'est
simplement du déclaratif pour le moment
pour les plateformes comment l'arcom
peut-elle contrôler les données de
visionnage de téléchargement des coups
de marketing qui permettent la
répartition des obligations entre cinéma
et audiovisuel et question subsidiaire
est-ce que vous avez le droit de
communiquer les montants investis en
prêt-achat et achat en 2021 pour Netflix
Amazon et Disney est-ce que cela
correspond en fait au montant qui était
prévu voilà c'est vrai qu'il passe leur
temps à dire qu'ils veulent avancer sur
la chronologie mais il faut bien
évidemment qu'ils puissent contribuer et
financer enfin participer au financement
du cinéma voilà
[Musique]
qui sont supplémentaires de c'est en
fait une mise au point
parce que il y a eu un échange comme ça
j'ai dit très exactement que les lois de
la concurrence sont strictes donc elles
peuvent être appliquées par une autorité
de régulation
sans interprétation trop importante il y
en a toujours
à partir du moment où la loi de 86 est
quasiment obsolète dans plein de
domaines notamment tout ce qui touche à
ce qui est entre la révolution libérée
et l'audiovisuel
vos interprétations
ne sont pas
quand je dis ou plus une grande marge
d'interprétation de ce que cette loi qui
ne régule pas ce secteur veut dire dans
son principe ou avec compris donc je
n'ai pas parlé d'indépendance de votre
jugement
voilà on peut avoir des désaccords c'est
normal mais je n'ai pas parlé
d'indépendance de votre jugement j'ai
parlé du fait que
votre interprétation que que j'ai
contesté mais ça c'est normal et c'est
des êtres humains qui composent votre
collège qui ont aussi leurs
interprétations et
voilà depuis le début vous avez
considéré que c'était nécessaire
vous l'avez dit depuis le début c'était
nécessaire par rapport aux évolutions
d'avoir un géant etc et que ça
n'atteindrait pas forcément au bon et
ça c'est nos interprétations mais je
n'ai pas dit que c'était une question
d'indépendance de votre part
juste répondre sur ce point je voudrais
deux questions celles qui ont été
posé peut-être voulez-vous juste
répondre sur ce point et puis on
clôturer
sur le sujet je conteste parfaitement la
conclusion je n'ai jamais dit ça j'ai
dit que des groupes il était normal que
des groupes s'adaptent aux évolutions
leurs contexte c'est la logique d'une
entreprise qui soit publique ou privée
et un marché qui évolue c'est normal
qu'ils prennent des initiatives et puis
de l'autre côté il y a la régulation et
que la régulation exacerait dès la
première heure j'ai dit que notre fil
rouge serait le pluralise et que la
décision serait prise de façon que les
gens et l'indépendante j'ai jamais donné
une propos et je vois pas comment
j'aurais pu le dire parce qu'une
décision collégiale disons que cette
opération à des vocation à se faire mais
c'est votre c'est votre analyse avant
que vous ne répondiez aux questions de
twentyland Archos mais je voudrais en
rajouter deux d'abord vous nous avez dit
il y a quelques minutes que vous pensez
que la convergence des acteurs du
secteur public était nécessaire mais
elle ne pourrait se faire sans qu'il y
ait une impulsion forte et ce que de
votre point de vue ça veut dire que les
comme sont un outil suffisant ou pas ou
insuffisant pour accélérer et mettre en
oeuvre cette convergence et sur un autre
sujet
plus en lien avec la vente de M6 par
rapport à la règle existante de
l'interdiction de vendre 5 ans suivant
le renouvellement des autorisations
est-ce que vous pensez que cette règle
est toujours pertinente et qu'elle
pourrait être la faire évoluer pour être
de nature
ne pas prendre une décision dans la
précipitation comme ça risque d'être le
cas si
leurs intentions de du propriétaire
actuel de M6 c'était
suivi des faits je rappelle que c'était
un des amendements qui avait proposé le
sénateurs
[Musique]
sur ce dernier point parce que nous
sommes dans un processus de
renouvellement d'autorisation qui se
fait dans un cadre juridique
donné et que je voudrais pas prendre un
propos donner un sentiment sur une à
l'égard des règles du jeu qui sont les
règles du jeu qui s'appliquent
aujourd'hui et en tant qu'autorité comme
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure notre mission
est d'appliquer la loi telle qu'elle
existe donc cette règle est celle qui
est en vigueur aujourd'hui si par Le
Mans souhaite un moment ou un autre
comme il l'avait fait par le passé se
ressaisir du sujet c'est bien évidemment
le droit souverain du Parlement mais à
ce stade je ne souhaite pas m'exprimer
sur ce sujet je pense pas que les cônes
soient suffisant pour une orientation
stratégique comme celle que j'évoquais
on en a une bonne illustration je trouve
avec les comme en cours d'exécution qui
partaient d'une assez bonne idée
d'ailleurs d'avoir des des obligations
spécifique à chaque entreprise et des
obligations communes
laissez la mise en oeuvre à la seule
bonne volonté des entreprises
je crois que c'est se heurte
à des inerties légitimes j'allais dire
d'entreprises qui ont leur logique
propre leur organisation propre leur
contrainte propre et donc il y a
nécessairement pour la mise en oeuvre
d'objectifs aussi ambitieux aussi
stratégiques que des actions de
convergence nécessairement besoin de
concevoir une gouvernance spécifique ça
c'est vraiment la conviction que je
retire après quatre ans puisque je
rentre maintenant dans le dernier tiers
de mon de mon mandat
sur les Smart madame la salatrice Darcos
donc on est un peu au début j'allais
dire on a signé des conventions avec ces
acteurs on applique strictement les
dispositions du du décret SMAD les
services en question donc sont tenus de
nous déclarer
ce qu'ils ont réalisé au titre de les
dispositions de la Convention et du
Règlement ça nous amène à être tout à
fait exigeant alors il y a
je pense à l'un des acteurs principaux
principaux contributeurs avec lequel on
a on a eu des échanges nourris qui les
ont obligés à bouger sur leur ligne nous
connaissons bien
les préoccupations qui peuvent
s'exprimer qui ne sont pas homogènes
entre le monde de l'audiovisuel et le
monde du cinéma les conventions qu'on a
conclu sont une première étape elles
sont conclues pour trois ans elle ne
préjuge pas d'accord interprofessionnel
il y a d'ailleurs des négociations qui
sont en cours qui prend et je le
souhaite venir enrichir les conventions
il y a d'autres éléments de débats qui
sont en toile de fond comme vous le
savez qui entrait à la chronologie des
médias
il faudrait pas que que ces acteurs ou
certains d'entre eux prennent des
postures trop raides dans cette dans
cette approche je pense que tout le
monde a intérêt à jouer le jeu de la
négociation et de la négociation
interprofessionnelle
c'est l'intérêt de des plateformes parce
qu'on voit bien que dans leur modèle
exposé les contenus nationaux est un
moyen de fidéliser leurs abonnés
d'élargir leur base c'est l'intérêt de
la filière d'avoir des financements des
financements supplémentaires et en tout
cas comme comme régulateur nous sommes
en dialogue avec les différents acteurs
si un moment il faut faire bouger les
paramètres ou aller plus loin et pouvoir
éventuellement de faire bouger la loi on
reviendra on reviendra vers vous
madame la sénatrice alors c'est bien sûr
un enjeu très très important pour nous
les contenus haineux pour nous la
priorité maintenant c'est la mise en
oeuvre du texte européen le DSA c'est
pour ça qu'on souhaiterait que le
l'autorité nationale qui sera en charge
de la mise en oeuvre du DSA et vous avez
compris que nous serions pas opposés à
être cette autorité puissant en liaison
avec les autres puissent être désigné
puisse être désigné rapidement parce que
c'est un texte complexe il faut aussi
adapter il faut anticiper et de forte
attente de nos concitoyens sur ces
sujets de haine en ligne et de contenu
ici en tout cas c'est un chantier sur
lequel on souhaite s'impliquer très
fortement
[Musique]